[Music]
elizabeth is in birmingham hi elizabeth
how are you
hi dave hi ken thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up
well my husband and i actually filed for
chapter 13 bankruptcy uh back in may
and guys this is a decision that we are
regretting right now um
at the time just long story short we
were in a bad financial place earlier
this year i had lost my job and so
we were working the baby steps we were
on baby step number two when all this
happened and
i think in a panic of realizing that we
were down to one income um
we panicked and uh did some stupid
things and got into more debt and then
realized that hey
uh we got to pay this off how are we
going to do it we weren't looking at the
bigger picture and so we filed for
chapter 13.
and fast forward to today we're in a
much better place i have a great job my
husband's doing well
and guys we do well every month except
that pesky payment that we have
it's really cutting into our monthly
income and we were we're in gazelle mode
right now we're selling everything that
we can sell we had a yard sale and we're
doing good and bringing in extra money
but in bankruptcy you can't you know you
get that payment and you got to stick
with it and we are actually we have an
appointment with our bankruptcy attorney
later this week to actually see about
just getting out of bankruptcy just
canceling it all together and uh taking
on the task ourselves and we would love
to get y'all's opinion of uh whether you
think we should do this or just keep at
it with chapter 13. okay
uh well first let's establish a couple
of things
once the
file has been opened on you at the
courthouse
that's where the phrase comes from
filing
bankruptcy
and a number has been assigned to you so
you have
filed bankruptcy you cannot un
bankruptcy you can voluntarily dismiss a
chapter 13 but if anyone ever asks the
question have you ever filed bankruptcy
the answer for the rest of your life is
yes
okay me too by the way
yes okay
i filed chapter 7 in 1988
so me too
been there done that uh and seven's a
lot worse than 13. so
uh but but that's really a misnomer
because right now what you're asking
about is the cash flow and what kind of
risk and stuff have you got so what kind
of debts do you have
our biggest one guys we have two car
payments and um that our cars were we
owe more on them than they were worth at
the time now since we filed i don't
really know the standing uh we also had
about 25 000 in credit card debt and
about 6 000 in personal loans no student
loans and that's all we have at this
time
okay and what do you owe on the two cars
uh the two cars right around uh probably
thirty thousand dollars each
okay and um
you think they're worth somewhere in
that vicinity
uh probably a little bit less um
probably around i think we could it may
be more just depending on how the market
is right now uh but i would say dave
probably around 26 or 27 000 at least
okay all right
um
and and so what do you guys make now
what's your household income now uh our
household income per month net after
health insurance taxes and all that
we're looking right around 5100 a month
um and then the bankruptcy is running
what's your house payment
uh we rent and our payment is 1400 a
month
okay
all right so the way you can kind of
analyze this is uh pretend like you took
a um
a baseball bat and you hit a hornet's
nest and you threw the hornet's nest in
a closet
and closed the door
okay you're getting ready to open the
door
oh lord
all of these people
are not mildly pissed they're gonna come
after you with everything they got and
you gotta have a plan for taking care of
every one of them if you're going to
open the door
okay okay so you need more information
on the cars can you get out of these
cars because you probably need to sell
both of them
uh yes sir we can we've actually got a
little bit of money from just the
gazelle intent of selling everything
stashed aside to where if we needed to
pay the difference we could and and then
you're going to get something to drive
for cash
yes sir
what was the 6 000 the 25 000 was credit
card debt and the 6000 was what
personal ones
okay to who
uh let's see yeah just lenders in
general um audio credit like personal
lines
okay yes sir yes sir they're gonna be
the worst
versus credit cards
okay because they're basically bottom
feeders
and they're
they're going to come after you um
really really aggressively so you're
going to knock those out really really
fast
the credit card companies are um
incompetent
inefficient
so the uh how how aggressively they
chase you will take them time
during that time you need to just be on
the phone with one at a time of them and
get a payment plan going
okay if you just start paying them
payments most of the time you 99 time
you shut them up
okay okay okay but you you can't just
ignore them
because now they've got you've got no
protection because federal bankruptcy
filing puts a stay an injunction like
telling a dog stay
on all of the creditors they can't touch
you they're the hornets in the closet
with the door closed when you
voluntarily dismiss you open the door
and out come all the hornets so you need
you need you you need a bug spray you
need uh fly swatter you need uh a hood
that's you know on your head or whatever
it is whatever metaphor we want to do
here to keep all this crap from getting
at you right and so yeah go ahead and
dumping the cars
uh and so forth all of that'll work uh
by the way inside the chapter 13 you can
probably get the trustees permission to
do the car deals
okay and dump the car deals and get your
cars all situated
and you know pay the payment for one or
two more months all of the payments
you're paying is going towards your
debts anyway you're not losing any money
by paying payments because you're going
to be paying payments after you come out
of this
so you're still going to have payments
and there's still going to be a bunch of
them
um you just want to make sure you got a
plan but i i'm with you if you can step
out of that 13 you probably can manage
it more efficiently than you can inside
the third team if you're willing to dump
these cars especially
wow
lesson learned
bankruptcy is not something you do
impulsively because i'm scared
this is the ramsey show